[Music]
so here's the deal as a millennial i
keep up with the trends i'm on social
media i'm on instagram reels checking
those out and of course you got to see
what's happening over on tik tok
and listen i'm a hard-working guy i'm
just out here trying to help people get
on a budget get out of debt
save for the future
and flying in the face of all of my hard
work
there's some people out there some gurus
that uh can't grow facial hair that are
out here telling you how to manage your
money
and better yet how to not manage your
money and one of those videos popped up
on my feed
and uh it made my blood boil and it's
all about how stupid budgeting is you
guys want to watch it with me the live
audience is not in yes i'll take that as
a go let's watch this video
here are the three reasons why budgeting
sucks reason number one it almost always
puts you in a bad mindset right you have
this negative feeling towards money
reason number two is because it's like a
diet right we go on a diet we tell
ourselves ourselves we're not going to
eat certain things budgeting we tell
ourselves we're not going to buy certain
things or we restrict ourselves and
reason number three is because we all
have limited willpower right just like a
diet you tell yourself you're not going
to eat that cookie eventually you break
down and you eat that cookie budgeting
we tell ourselves we're not going to buy
those shoes or whatever it might be
eventually we end up breaking down and
buying that thing and then we just feel
bad about ourselves
oh man
that actually he's hilarious he should
try stand-up comedy instead of being a
financial advisor
okay
so let's break this down
budgeting sucks because it puts you in a
bad mindset
okay all right so the alternative here
let's just play this logic out if we're
saying never do a budget because it puts
you in a bad mindset instead let's just
spend
every dollar we make and more and never
worry about it what a great mindset to
have right until the payments show up
and you're wondering where your money
went
and you can't afford your four walls
how's that for a bad mindset
yeah
okay the next one
was budgeting is like a diet and diets
are bad
okay well let's look at how people lose
weight this is i'm not a scientist i'm
not claiming to be but it's all about
caloric deficit
so if you burn more calories than you
take in you will lose weight
if you lift if you live on less than you
make
you can build wealth
and so budgeting
is a necessary part of that just like
watching your food intake
so the last one uh was willpower he said
humans have terrible willpower so
budgeting sucks
okay he is right on that one we have
terrible willpower he said it sets you
up for failure too oh it sets you up for
failure thank you james it sets you up
for failure because we have limited
willpower as humans and therefore we
should just out earn our stupidity keep
spending and spending never make a plan
never pay attention never look at the
mirror bury our head in the sand oh wait
that's what america has done okay i'm
seeing what's happening now that is why
78 of people live paycheck to paycheck
because they've all decided to be like
this guy and just go budgeting sucks
let's not do that
let me hit you with the reel on what a
budget does
a budget is telling your money where to
go instead of wondering where it went a
budget is permission to spend that's all
it is so a budget is actually the most
freedom you can have with money
because you know exactly what's
happening on paper every single month
and when you make a budget to go on a
thousand dollar vacation
and you stick to that budget
you come home with just good memories
sweet times maybe a tan if you're lucky
i can't get one
but when you do it without a budget you
come back with credit card debt
and you wonder how long you're going to
be paying for this vacation that
happened three months ago
and you're stressed out because you know
that bill is going to come due
and that's where most of america is at
they've got the credit card payments
they've got the car loans they have
student loan payments
and i get it budgeting is uh
it's tough to do it's tough to stick to
it has uh it requires discipline and so
yes if you think discipline is stupid
then uh i really question how you're
doing in every single other area of your
life
do you show up to work on time do you
work hard do you communicate with your
spouse
do you read books what other areas are
you just going well head in the sand who
cares willpower's hard diets are stupid
puts me in a bad mindset anytime you
make me work out or eat healthy
goodness gracious
but this is what people on the internet
are seeing and they're hitting the like
button and they're commenting and
they're saying oh my gosh yes dave
ramsey's the worst he doesn't want me to
have nice things no dave wants you to
have nice things he doesn't want nice
things to have you
that's the difference
he wants you to buy all the things that
you want to buy
but when you do it with other people's
money you put yourself in a really
really poor risky financial situation
so
that's my take on budgets
and if you listen to this guy you're
going to agree budgeters don't have fun
you have to be really good at math only
people who struggle need a budget only
people who are out of debt need a budget
budgeting takes too much time
budgets are too rigid
too rigid guess what you control the
budget the budget doesn't control you
all we're saying is list out your
expenses
list out your income let's make sure
that we have enough income to cover the
expenses
it's that simple
okay my little baby rant is over i can't
handle it guys how many more of these
tick tocks are you gonna send us it's
too much i'm getting messages every
single day from viewers like you going
oh my gosh please respond to this and
there's only so much time in the day to
respond to stupidity that's the truth
and so you keep sending them because
it's entertaining for me
but i can't guarantee you it'll make the
show